[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
rebecca hey mark welcome back thanks
nice to see you again i found you
sleeping on the sidewalk again yeah i
was really tired and he was up all night
i wasn't having fun
how are you how are you getting by i'm
kidding all right
no i mean literally how are you getting
by oh yeah
i know i i found a good song
people give you money they'll give them
money sometimes
ow [ __ ]
what's going on how's your health
i think i cracked my rib from what i
don't know it's been hurting for the
last few days
you're pissing me off
you don't you seem worse than ever
i i don't know yeah i may be
i'm doing all right i'm doing really
well i'm just really tired the last
couple times you've come by you skipped
off after i gave you some money and
and never came back no i don't drool
anyway i missed you
oh
yeah i see you sleeping all day which
tells me that you're
i've seen you several times sleeping
during the day so it tells me that
you're up all night
no i sleep during the night as well it's
just easier to bring the legs like the
sun so what are your
what drugs are you playing around with
lately
honestly i've been mostly sober lately
like i don't even really do drugs
anymore really
yeah is this just your natural
personality
yeah yeah without any medication
no
you have shirts now that's great
merchandise yeah
[Music]
what uh
what do you ever talk to your family
yeah i called my mom recently
doing great
um
she's just busy with work
does she worry about you
no not really i mean maybe all the time
i don't know i'm [ __ ] i bet you she's
probably very worried about you i'm sure
she is
i don't know
what would you guys talk about i owe my
mom oh my god i love my mom you love
your mom
that's nice to hear
we're getting the truth out of you
eventually after about five or six of
these talks yeah
i know it's the moment
god
does your mom want you to come home i
think so
and you know in the picture then you
come home
would you be open to doing that yeah i
think i'm here to come home
really
you got your mom's your mom's phone
number
i don't but i know how i can reach her
maybe and i was using the city had kind
that's good
i'm gonna write my phone number on your
hand so you can give her your my number
okay i can help you get home
i mean she can probably help make that
happen too
i know what's going on
nice what makes you emotional here i
just really miss her
i didn't think she was going to turn out
this way so
that's so good i'm going to feel i'm
just really tired they're going to need
to get them to me
well you say you didn't think it would
turn out this way you mean coming to l.a
no i mean
maybe
yes i mean i
yeah
sorry i'm just really tired today
how do you spend your time now
i know
i had the feeling when i first met you
maybe you were going to
raves or parties or things like that but
now yeah i know a city shut down just
genuinely bored
it just seems like you're mainly just
existing on the streets yeah right like
a homeless like nothing yeah like a
russian
destitute person yeah
your potential is so much greater i
think the potential is really stagnant
nothing's really happening
right
yeah
i think getting home would be a great
thing for you i think so too i think
it's just time to go home
it's kind of hard it's really idiotic
so trying to be really dumb but it's
fine i think i think
so when you
communicate with your family your mom
how do you do it um i know on free on
instagram
[Music]
all right we're gonna try to set that up
all right thanks
so do you have any friends at this point
no
you're just like existing by yourself
yeah there's the whole city's dancing
[ __ ] yeah
you've had any bad things happen lately
not really
kind of right now
you're just being about lunch i see you
sleeping everywhere
all over down all over downtown
so exhausted
yeah yeah
all right we're done
sorry i'm just exhausted yeah i
understand yeah i'll give you some i'll
give you some dough and you can go in
your merry way
but i'm to try to make sure that you
connect with your mom and maybe i can
help out with that i don't think it'll
be too hard
okay
all right
let me make your day a little bit better